the jurogan experience yeah you're in a
jiu jitsu
i remember that i remember i ran into
you at the ufc it was a couple of years
ago and
you were you're like really into jiu
jitsu like you train hard
i was super super into it until kovid
hit
and then when covet hit i just yeah
i got really really nervous because i
have asthma and
autoimmune [ __ ] so um i just
i i got really nervous about training so
close with anybody that i took a break
from it but i'm
i'm anxious to get back i want i can't
wait to train
it's a good humbler that's a good thing
to keep you balanced
it's the best thing i found for i mean
outside of
meditation for me it's two totally
different things but
it's kind of different but not but yeah
you're right
yeah this jiu jitsu people are some of
the calmest people i've ever met in my
life
they're all chill totally yeah
especially when they get into like flow
rolling
mm-hmm like that is meditative that is
meditation sure
yeah i love it i think even like hard
sparring is meditative because you're
forced to think only of that thing
and when you think about that thing only
it acts as like a cleansing
yes it blows all that and also it's so
hard to do
that regular stuff seems easy yeah like
regular live scenes
yeah some some pitches on top of you
trying to college
yeah yeah but it's also like really
empowering when you're collar choking
you're like when you're mounting on
someone yeah when you're mounting
on someone and you're just yeah it's
it's crazy right it's empowering for
sure
when you do you remember the first time
you tap somebody out
i actually don't uh that's good that
means you probably tapped a bunch of
people out
um i i i've tapped out a few people in
my time in the wild though
yeah what's really wild is like when you
surpass yourself like you
think i don't know i just i never
thought that i'd get
a blue belt like i just never thought
that i'd be a belt in anything
i'm i'm a singer like and then
hard work pays off and it's just really
cool when when you get to
prove yourself wrong well if you get to
a blue belt you're
at purple belt and if you get the purple
belt you can get the black belt totally
that's all it is it's just just keep
where are you training
so i was training at unbreakable okay
yeah
in west hollywood that's a great gym i
love that gym
so much famous people can go there too
it's like yes for whatever reason snoop
goes there
where's khalifa goes there stallone goes
there yeah
so um the reason why it's so chill
is they have like a no like cameras
policy it's kind of like the soho house
of
yeah and a lot of athletes go in and
train there too but um
but it's private and it's super chill i
used to train there and then i
yeah um then i started training at my
apartment building that i was living in
and i got a house so i just will train
there but
so do you um have you gone to like
other jiu jitsu schools like if you're
on the road have you ever done that
i have yeah i've gone to random
places throughout the country um
but i couldn't tell you the name and
there weren't
also a lot of people in there right um
limited to the amount of people
just a small amount of people that you
can train with yeah um
or or just my trainer you know it's hard
for me i
not a lot of people wanted to let me
train with
other people in like a like a outside of
a private lesson
did they worry about like you getting
hurt yeah they were worried about people
being like and then you sue the [ __ ] out
of them right or or
just not being able to walk on stage
right
oh my god right you know so many heel
hooks and then
yeah oh sorry everybody i lost my acl
right right training i have worn boots
on stage
too so i'm i'm a very clumsy person
and they've worn boots like broken foot
boots
broken foot boots really what happened
to your foot so i broke my ankle
in 2012 i think or 2013
and then i broke my foot in 2018
and i still had to tour the broken foot
yeah i just bedazzled it
you bedazzled your boot and i did it
myself like
in the dressing in my hotel room in
ireland like the cheapest like
old jewels and hot glue that's hilarious
yeah catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience